et les cyclonies
les pays du sud-ouest de l'océan Indien
présentent des réalités
socio-économiques bien différentes les
unes des autres pourtant il partage un
dénominateur commun l'exposition risque
naturel
près de 100 millions de personnes vivent
dans cette partie du monde
elle se répartissent dans de petits
États insulaires en développement comme
les Comores les Seychelles où il Maurice
sur la partie continentale aux
Mozambique et en Tanzanie ou bien encore
sur la grande île de Madagascar elles
sont régulièrement victimes de
catastrophes naturelles cyclone à
Madagascar ou à la Réunion inondations à
Maurice ou au Comores sécheresse en
Tanzanie mouvement de terrain épidémie
et enfin éruption volcanique la liste
est longue
chaque année plusieurs de ces aléas
naturels menacent simultanément les
populations de l'océan Indien si bien
qu'au cours de ces 30 dernières années
plus de 90 catastrophes naturelles ont
touché les pays de la région les effets
prévisibles du changement climatique
risque par ailleurs d'augmenter la
fréquence et l'intensité des allées à
naturel auxquelles ces populations sont
les plus exposées certains dérèglements
sont d'ores et déjà perceptibles avec le
changement climatique il y a des
bouleversements qui entraînent d'autres
bouleversements depuis quelques temps
nous avons eu à gérer plus du tout un
cyclone mais des pluies torrentielles
qui ont provoqué des dégâts
considérables
toutes ces catastrophes ont des
conséquences immédiates pour les
populations en termes d'accès à
l'habitat à l'eau à l'assainissement et
à la sécurité alimentaire elles ont
également des conséquences indirectes et
à plus long terme en particulier sur la
santé des populations et leurs moyens de
subsistance
humaine système
en plus des pertes humaines et des
dégâts matériels les catastrophes
engendrent des pertes financières
susceptibles de paralyser l'économie des
pays concernés plusieurs mois après la
survenue d'une catastrophe
il a été estimé environ 333 millions de
dollars de dommages et de pertes après
donc de passage d'un cyclone à
Madagascar ça représentait à l'époque
environ 4% du produit intérieur brut du
pays les conséquences des catastrophes
dans l'océan Indien dépassent donc
largement les bilans établis en urgence
au cours des premières heures qui
suivent le passage d'un cyclone ou la
survenue d'une inondation aux personnes
blessées décédées il faut ajouter les
impacts économiques et sociaux
route détruite maison et colle et
hôpitaux effondrée paralysie des
transports à des échanges commerciaux
sont autant de facteurs qui
compromettent le développement de toute
une population
face à ces situations dramatiques les
acteurs humanitaires ONG agence
onusienne et le moment de la Croix-Rouge
se mobilisent
plusieurs fois par an les volontaires et
le personnel de la Croix-Rouge et du
Croissant Rouge interviennent lors
d'opération d'urgence leur objectif
consiste à fournir au plus vite des
moyens de subsistance aux populations
affectées par les catastrophes
naturelles
les activités d'urgence c'est une
activité qui doit toujours être continue
et les équipes d'urgence dans le système
national peuvent être toujours
actifs et prêt à intervenir en cas de
besoin les équipes de la Croix-Rouge
sont spécialisés pour répondre à
l'ensemble des besoins des populations
en situation d'urgence elle mène ainsi
des évaluations rapides
identifient les besoins prioritaires et
conduisent des opérations de premiers
secours
la construction d'abris temporaires le
traitement de l'eau et la distribution
de bien la première nécessité font
également partie des compétences de ces
équipes régionales de réponse au
catastrophes
la première activité qu'on avait fait
pendant l'urgence c'est on a on a essayé
de déblayer des labouts dans des maisons
et des dans les citerne après le
deuxième la deuxième activité c'est que
on a nettoyé le système dans l'océan
Indien la Croix-Rouge intervient à
travers la pirroie cette plateforme
d'intervention régionale réunit les
différentes entités de la Croix Rouge et
du Croissant Rouge répartis dans la
région
dans le cadre de son volet de
préparation et de réponse aux urgences
elle développe des plans d'intervention
prépositionnent des stocks de matériel
et forment des équipiers plusieurs
opérations d'urgence sont ainsi menées
chaque année au côté de la Fédération
internationale des Sociétés de la
Croix-Rouge et du Croissant Rouge et des
Sociétés nationales c'est la garantie
d'une réponse adaptée efficace en cas de
crise
of the this
at
coordinaples
les dispositifs de déploiement de ces
acteurs démontrent chaque année leur
efficacité il faut moins de 72 heures au
moment de la Croix-Rouge pour fournir du
matériel humanitaire et déployer des
spécialistes en gestion des catastrophes
plusieurs tonnes de kit d'urgence et des
dizaines d'unités de traitement d'eau
pour ne citer que ces deux exemples sont
acheminés chaque année vers les zones
sinistrées la réponse d'urgence est
efficace et il remplaçable mais elle ne
suffit pas contrairement à ce que l'on
peut penser ces aléas ne constituent pas
toujours un risque pour les populations
les impacts d'un cyclone d'une
inondation d'un mouvement de terrain
peuvent être considérablement amoindries
si des actions de prévention ont été
menées
les risques naturels ne sont pas une
fatalité ils peuvent être gérés et
réduits
bien efficace les actions de réduction
du risque de catastrophe ne sont pas
spectaculaires peu médiatisés et donc
difficile à financer
techniquement une catastrophe c'est une
rencontre de deux composantes un aléas
comme par exemple un cyclone qui est un
aller à climatique et une vulnérabilité
un cyclone dans une zone désertique ce
n'est pas une catastrophe un cyclone qui
arriverait en zone urbaine où il y a
beaucoup de population ça peut être une
catastrophe travailler autour de la
thématique des catastrophes c'est agir
avant pendant et après c'est le cycle de
gestion des risques les activités de
réduction du risque de catastrophe sont
au cœur de l'action du mouvement
Croix-Rouge
la réduction des risques de catastrophes
c'est un ensemble d'actions qui vont
être faites pour réduire l'impact d'une
catastrophe naturelle sur des
populations donc ça va se travailler sur
des connaissances de l'information
savoir ce que c'est que canal naturel un
cyclone comment ça se forme il peut y
avoir aussi des actions je dirais plus
concrètes avec de la construction par
exemple de murs de protection qui vont
entrer qui vont être construits en amont
des catastrophes parce que le risque est
connu ou qui pourront être aussi
également réalisées lors de la phase
post-urgence le changement climatique
qui affecte la planète n'épargne pas
l'océan Indien étant à aggraver la
situation la hausse du niveau de l'océan
contamine les ressources d'eau douce
côtière les épisodes de sécheresse et
l'inondation sont plus longs et
fragilisent des écosystèmes
enfin l'augmentation de la température
des océans favorise la création des
cyclones ce n'est qu'à travers des
programmes de réduction des risques que
ces changements peuvent être atténués
pour permettre au pays de se développer
et aux habitants de vivre en sécurité
il est important de savoir
se protéger se soigner se signaler etc
et donc c'est le but de cette formation
d'aller apprendre aux enfants ou aux
personnes en état d'handicap
comment faire
hamlé